heathland used to blanket much of
Southern England
now it's one of the rarest habitats in
Europe
a shrinking home to thousands of species
this is Ling Heather which is another
word for common Heather
on horsel common in Surrey Rangers are
helping rare Wildlife cling on during
the Spring and Summer you will have
night jars nesting and they they fly
from as I said Africa 4 000 miles away
to here around the back of working
according to the new living planet index
compiled by the environmental charity
WWF populations of more than 5 000 key
species fell by an average of 69 between
1970 and 2018. South and Central America
was the region under greatest threat
with population numbers down by 94 loss
of forests from logging and agriculture
is a key factor and populations of
freshwater species including fish and
amphibians are also significantly down
by 83 percent as the human settlements
grow near lakes and rivers
this is a code red for nature and
Humanity not only do healthy ecosystems
sustain life on Earth but destruction of
habitats such as Forest bring us into
closer contact with wild animals
increasing the chances of Novel viruses
triggering a new pandemic
WWF warns that the threatened rollback
of Environmental Protections by the new
UK government would be catastrophic for
nature
we were incredibly concerned the UK is
one of the most nature depleted
countries on the planet and we know that
a healthy Society a healthy economy is
dependent on a thriving natural world
foreign
the government says it is committed to
reversing the decline in nature by 2030
but WWF warns action needs to start now
and Britain should not duck its
responsibility
Thomas More Sky News